hey guys how's it going today we are
making something really amazing it is a
wedding cake for my sister so she's
getting married and I thought you know
what a nice gesture it'd be if I made
her a wedding cake her special day
so we're gonna start with these boxes
okay I think I'm gonna make it terrible
maybe 20 layers of a cake and we're
gonna stack them up and to do this my
friend ed is here and you want to bring
over your contraption so we realized
that when you make layered cakes you're
supposed to have support systems in
place so what we didn't have our actual
cake supports but what we did have was
an abundance of Lego yeah so ed made
that you're too tall for the screen look
you're cut off
I'm Rob we can see you up here though
well the hard part is going to be making
and baking 16 to 20 cakes so I think I'm
gonna try to do like four at a time do
you think I can fit four cakes in this
Dooku and then we can measure on the
side measure and then it's wider as it
goes up so it's too fine let's just all
what did you get it oh we got a lot eggs
so 1/2 cup and a half cup equals what
kids a whole cup cake math all right
let's get one cup of oil and you go
here's our eggs in our cake map we
determined that we need about 36 eggs my
least talented subject Thank You
subjects right now take that three X
plus three X equal 6x here we go ready
it's looking pretty good I think so
Schultz two cakes all right monies into
the oven and then um make some more oh
[Music]
nice shootin we um
the only problem is now look how much
this cakes are rising that's not looking
promising in there so here's the problem
those cakes are rising it's been five
minutes it's yeah Wow this is not good
maybe it'll be a really tall cake maybe
Lily I'll call her real doll hit count
four five six your slowest pour into the
biggest thing oh there these are rising
well you know what I can do
are you to juggle see if you can crack
them on your ring and sling them into
here I can't do that
[Music]
I think Briana's really gonna like her
wedding cake who agree for eight
do you think she'll like it we've got
we've got a we were these ones going we
still have two more two more
yeah we'll just on the top yep after
that a little little so how do we do
this um should we hmm well we just do it
okay help pops wrong let's just try and
lift it straight up
possibly yeah I'm pretty sure oh my gosh
I've got an idea say the idea that idea
Hey I'll move the cake down here yeah I
don't hate that idea but we don't know
how much this weighs whoo um wait a
minute wait a minute let's just use or
hey watch this okay that's a bad idea
also let's just get this out of here cuz
this isn't helping yeah no it's okay we
got this I'm so terrified
this is Brees day this is Grayson this
is Brees day no I can't see okay oh my
god all right you're into the bar take
the bull get rid look warn the boss the
gates I got the cake the cakes weird
girl decides yeah this is where I got on
the move no wait it's okay it's fine we
got this is totally fine that's okay
it's okay
breeze day we forgot the Lego thing it's
okay we just kind of move us a little
over oh wow okay this is blaze cake okay
move your hands see we got it's very
sturdy it's pretty sturdy to be honest
I'm surprised rotated hey do you
remember when we said we wanted to put
two more cakes on top of it maybe that's
not
yeah it just needs to get hard okay
alright if you let go we're time again
where's it gonna what user hits no
that's good but I just honest let me
just get I need to just learn as much on
as possible I don't take off my rings I
just honestly this is the this is the
easiest thing to do like let's just be
real
yeah I wash my hands and start um I shut
down with it that's a statement
yeah wasn't this weighs like fifty
pounds so um this is what this is used
for Roy and I were like why would anyone
ever use a massive thing like this do
you think reason I like it John
yeah so my fingers feel like they weight
10 pounds imagine what your body is
gonna feel like when you eat her cake go
get Matt tell him to come here and check
this out I'm gonna Isis other side all
right
are you sure cuz ya know it's pretty
sturdy okay all right go get Matt and
Jenna all right everybody this here is
Briana's wedding cake your glutes yeah
that must be in the camera yeah if you
wanted one disc you literally can't even
are you gonna lift that you have any
left
let me get some help give any stability
yeah god this is so incredibly happy I
don't think I know what happened mistake
I have to get a thumbnail picture should
not I don't get some not mature than
this entire video game he's gonna drop
watch out for Matty get get Matty cuz we
don't want him to get in okay ready
okay that's okay no no no many cuz
there's I got icing on the floor alright
okay so Jenna you just can you take a
picture hurry up yeah yeah viruses get a
price oh no Jenna get watch out for men
Man Man Man Man Man me no no
[Music]
honey nobody hit the picture you get the
picture well no I couldn't unlock the
phone so wait so what you're telling me
is there's no Katie II we could probably
eat it off the cloth I like coming from
that was a terrible idea and now there's
no cake for anybody there is actually
lobbying in the top it's fine right in
here in this middle these are all fine
oh my god hello who suck our we have a
food fight in your kitchen
no just reach into the middle yes this
is fine eats off your arm
we got this it's great I'm actually very
upset about this because do you realize
how long I'm good in the kitchen
I'm parents making this big yes you guys
really all got a handful this is good
it's so good I stepped in it that's fine
papaya I think this creative
[Music]
I also ate kpop more oh my god ah
calabrese day is ruined Oh more like my
day is ruined true you and was supposed
to leave like three hours oh I'm really
sorry it's fine as long as brie knows
that I gave her my saturday oh gosh this
is for Brie look it looks like a little
case of teeth hello pre-wedding
quesadilla this is for Brie this is for
Brie when I think about my success in
the kitchen this is not what I think of
Jenna look extra tier nice yeah this is
a successful day yeah it's always moving
in this kitchen for so long that I my I
don't have any emotions anymore my
apartment or pets are like hi guys thank
you so much for watching
I send my sister some well wishes on her
big happy day and I'm gonna go clean up
this mess now I honestly actually
thought this was going to be a
successful cake until well I mean until
this happened but I don't even I'm so
emotionally drained from the hours and
hours that we've been in this kitchen
making this cake and this is what
happened I'm actually kind of sad like
we I know I was I just like in to make a
good cake for once my hands are really
soft
I'm really sad
[Music]
you flatter yourself to close out I was
sending you those